thank you I'm here to present the award
for Best Documentary short film which is
my favorite award this is easily my
favourite subject it really is because
this is the one academy award that has
an opportunity to change a life because
i mean i'm happy for all you but you
came here winners and you're leaving
millionaires it's not going to make that
big a difference the rest of the Oscars
are going to mansions and the homes of
people with good unions and who will
always work these people
this is documentary short film you have
not
it's not even documentary feature you
know Al Gore got one of those and
Michael Moore got this is no you cannot
make a dime on this you these people who
will never be rich as long as they live
so this Oscar means something because
all they do is tell stories that are
important now you all do but you also
get rich but these people all they got
is this Oscar is going home in a Honda
Civic
the person who owns this this ostrich
would be the nicest thing they ever
owned in their life it's going to give
them anxiety to keep it in their crappy
apartment here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject five and teen
12 David dark and green loser shall be
on the lines
Courtney Marsh and Jerry Frank cloud
lawns Minh specters of the Shoah Adam
benzine a girl in the river the price of
forgiveness
sharmeen obaid Chinoy last day of
freedom
dee Hobart Jones and Noemi talisman and
the Oscar goes to Matt max no
a girl in the river the price of
forgiveness
this is the second Oscar and second
nomination for sharmeen obaid to know
thank God I have two of them now oh this
is what happens when determined women
get together from Sabah the woman in my
film who remarkably survived and honour
killing and shared her story to Sheila
Nevins and Lisa Braun from Lisa Heller
from HBO to Tina Brown who supported me
from day one to the men who champion
women like Jeff parts in my film whose
edited the film to us at Farooqi to my
friends yard who bought this film to the
government to all the brave men out
there like my father and my husband who
push women to go to school and work and
who want a more just society for women
last week this week the Pakistani Prime
Minister has said that he will change
the law on honor killing after watching
this term that is the power of film